to Ukraine now where another wave of
Russian attacks has bombarded the
capital kiev's military Administration
says it shot down 15 drones on Monday
morning Ukraine has been rushing to
restore power to cities after Russian
strikes destroyed parts of the energy
grid the attacks have plunged much of
the country Into Darkness during
freezing winter temperatures let's bring
in Charles Stratford who joins us live
now from Keith hello there Charles what
more can you tell us about this barrage
of attacks in the capital
yeah this is just the latest barrage of
attacks this time using what has been
announced by the Ukrainian military as
Iranian Shaheed drones the military's
saying that uh
approximately 35 drones targeted various
targets across the country at least 20
of those drones
targeting places of critical
infrastructure across the capital city
the military saying that 30 of those
drones were were shot down sorry 20 of
those Jones were shot down in this
latest barrage of course this comes only
a couple of days after one of the
biggest attacks on the capital city
those attacks using missiles and we know
the kind of pressures that the
authorities here are under in in trying
to restore electricity across the
country to areas worse affected the
mayor of the Ukrainian Capital Kiev has
come out in the last hour or so and said
that there is ongoing work
um trying to to restore this critical
infrastructure we understand that one of
the main targets was actually targeted
last week as well that's um one of these
sub stations are so important for the
supply of electricity and heat
the president zielinski last night said
that an additional three million homes
had had electricity and heat restored to
them since those attacks on Friday yes
it's just another example of just how
vulnerable Ukraine and the capital city
in particular is and how the Russian
seemingly can Target these areas act
will but also an indication so far at
least of just how effective
this the missile defense systems are
that the ukrainians have but of course
they are continuously asking for more
defensive systems because of course
these temperatures these winter
temperatures continue to drop we've got
a number of months at least two or three
months of very heavy and and difficult
winter conditions ahead and potentially
yes millions of Ukrainian civilians
could be a expect you to buy these
attacks now of course Russia sees these
as being legitimate targets because
President Putin sees them as being
connected to the military Ukraine and
its Western backers continue to consider
these as basically war crimes because of
the sheer number of Ukrainian civilians
that are affected by them and Charles
tell us a little bit more about the
Russian president's visit to Belarus the
first time in more than three years
what's the significance of that trip
well a hugely significant trip by the
Russian president to his ally Alexander
lukashenga the president of Belarus of
course Belarus was used as a staging
point for The Invasion on February the
24th the Belarusian president has
repeatedly said that Belarusian troops
will not be used in any offensive but of
course A lot has changed as this war
continues and we know that the Russians
are basically not succeeded in their
offensives
um on on the on Kiev on the capital they
were pushed back in the early stages of
the ball we know that they are
struggling also to make grounds in the
East they have withdrawn from the
obviously the large city of hersan in
the south
but of course the Ukrainian military
establishment here are very concerned
that as Russia continues to struggle
they are concerned of a possible attack
from the Belarusian border
um the head of the Ukrainian military
last week uh Vitale zaluzny said that he
believes up to 200 000 Russian troops
are being prepared for what he describes
as a winter offensive he says that he
knows the units the number of units that
he has he knows the number of units that
he needs the ukrainians need and he says
that he is not going to touch these
units in preparation for any potential
offensive in his words no matter how
difficult that is as the fighting
continues so yes this meeting in Belarus
between Putin and lukashenko comes at a
very ominous time indeed Charles we
appreciate the update as always Charles
Stratford live for us there in Keith